[Applaus]
herr präsident liebe kolleginnen liebe
kollegen diese debatte hier heute
markiert eine zäsur
frau bundeskanzlerin sie haben
angekündigt nicht mehr für das amt der
bundesvorsitzenden ihrer partei zu
kandidieren
aus diesem grund ist diese debatte eine
danach nach dieser entscheidung
wir sehen es in den internationalen
medien
es beginnt jetzt bereits die betrachtung
ihrer gesamten amtszeit ihres
politischen lebens werks das werden
dereinst historiker abschließend
betrachten aber es verändert trotzdem
die art und weise der auseinandersetzung
mit ihnen und ihrer regierung wo man hat
es ja jetzt auch ihren beitrag heute
bereits angemerkt
nicht nur sie läuft noch eine realität
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen und ich
glaube noch habe ich nur in der sache
beschrieben wie nur sie frau
bundeskanzlerin sondern auch der
bundesminister des inneren hat
angekündigt nicht mehr für den vorsitz
seiner partei zur verfügung zu stehen
und das hat natürlich auswirkungen auf
die regierung mit einer gewissen
wahrscheinlichkeit wird nämlich kein
vorsitzender einer der
koalitionsparteien dem kabinett
angehören und das zeigt ein sven
parteien so auf distanz zu ihrer eigenen
regierung gehen
dann stehen wir nicht am anfang an etwas
sondern wir werden zeuge des endes von
etwas
das kann ja aber auch befreiend wirken
es kann ja auch befreiend frau
bundeskanzler und wir haben gehört wie
sie in straßburg vor dem europäischen
parlament gesprochen haben und wir haben
das begrüßt weil es trat eine angela
merkel auf die visionen beschrieben hat
und wir unterstützen sie wenn sie die
vision einer wirklichen europäischen
armee für sich selbst reklamieren auf
uns können sie in dieser frage baum
wir wünschen uns jetzt konkrete
maßnahmen und schritte was führt uns
denn es ist ja eine der fragen wo wir
dringend mehr europäische gemeinsamkeit
wollen in unserem landen in diesem
parlament gibt es ja einige die glauben
deutsche interessen zu vertreten wenn
sie nur auf nationale antworten setzen
machen wir uns bitte gemeinsam klar es
gibt eine konfliktlinie in unserem land
weil es menschen gibt die von offenheit
von vielfalt von digitalisierung
globalisierung und migration den
verschiebungen auf der weltbühne vor
allen dingen einschränkungen ihres
eigenen lebens erwarten
und hier gibt es leute die sagen die
antwort auf diese angst ist dass wir uns
im nationalstaat verschanzen die
wahrheit ist auf diese großen
herausforderungen kann man nur antworten
mit gemeinsamer außen gemeinsame
sicherheitspolitik gemeinsame
handelspolitik gemeinsam strategien für
an digitalen binnenmarkt bei diesen
fragen ist nicht offen ob wir das
europäisch gemeinsam machen da ist nur
offen wann wir endlich zu europäischer
gemeinsamkeit in diesen tagen hin
frau bundeskanzlerin sie haben haben
aufgenommen dass die französische armee
aus bewegung und der alte in vielen
fragen zusammenarbeiten
wir sind aber nicht deckungsgleich ich
hoffe sagen zu können dass die deutschen
liberalen herrn makro näher stehen als
ihre partei aber trotzdem sind wir nicht
deckungsgleich
wir sehen doch welche entwicklungen es
in italien gibt wo eine links und rechts
populistische regierung fahrlässig die
fiskalregeln
brechen will und ihren eigenen privaten
bankensektor in turbulenzen bringen wird
in einer solchen phase ist es falsch
über die vergemeinschaftung von risiken
und finanzen zu sprechen
in einer solchen phase muss die
finanzpolitische eigenverantwortung
eines jeden mitglieds der währungsunion
betont werden genau die falsche
prioritätensetzung frau bundeskanzlerin
sie haben gesprochen heute über das
wachstum und genau an diesem punkt muss
man zweifel in ihren beitrag heute
setzen denn wir wissen das wachstum die
dynamik in deutschland steht eben nicht
mehr zur verfügung wie über ganz weite
teile ihrer bisherigen amtszeit
der bundesfinanzminister hat es gestern
da getan
wir können nicht sicher sein dass es
tatsächlich in der wirtschaft so
weitergeht wie bisher dass die
staatsanleihen weiter so prosperieren
dass wir uns auf rekordbeschäftigung
stützen können all das sind keine
garantien
und deshalb ist es nun notwendig dass
wir auch die politische konsequenzen
ziehen
dass er wieder stärker in den blick
nehmen wie wir auch zukünftig unsere
wettbewerbsfähigkeit behaupten in ihrer
aufzählung des handelns ihrer regierung
mit blick in den etat gestellt ich nicht
fest dass diese neue wirtschaftliche
realität sich tatsächlich auch bereits
abbilden würde in den prioritäten
baukindergeld mütter rente brücken
teilzeit und und und alles überwiegend
konsumtive aufgaben sie setzten keine
impulse dafür den etat zukünftig zu
finanzieren
sie schaffen ansprüche wie den etat
zukünftig strangulieren werden
frau bundeskanzlerin und das ist mit
blick auf die weiteren dicken
ungefährlich sie reden inzwischen anders
als die handeln sie selbst wollen den
solidaritätszuschlag abschaffen so
äußert sie auch der
bundeswirtschaftsminister
zwei der bewerber über für den
cdu-vorsitz fordern eine
unternehmenssteuerreform in den papieren
der cdu csu bundestagsfraktion zur
sommer
so war das ebenfalls enthalten
fortwährend hören wir also in der tat
das steuerpolitische umfeld hat sich
verändert bürgerinnen und bürger und
betriebe müssten entlastet werden was
wir aber nur finden ist zusätzliche
belastungen wie beispielsweise bei der
parität bei der gesetzlichen
krankenversicherung sie handeln anders
als sie reden aber wer den mund spitzt
der muss irgendwann auch pfeifen frau
bundeskanzlerin sonst verliert man
glaubwürdigkeit
also es geht ja es geht ja es geht ja
noch weiter
also nach der rente mit 63 durch die
qualifizierte fachkräfte vom
arbeitsmarkt ferngehalten werden die wir
dringend brauchen wird gesprochen über
ein allgemeines pflichtjahr die
sozialdemokraten wollen sich beliebt
machen dadurch dass alle beschäftigten
einmal im jahr einen monat auf kosten
des staates bezahlten urlaub bekommen
können und bündnis 90/die grünen führen
eine debatte über eine garantie
sicherung mit der mal eben mir nichts
dir nichts 30 milliarden euro
die steuern erhöht werden sollen nicht
um in bildung zu investieren so haben
das geld denjenigen zu geben die nicht
arbeiten wollen mit einer solchen
politik wurde mal unser land vorsätzlich
beschädigen wenn ich ständig überhaupt
gar nicht ich schäme mich überhaupt gar
nicht dass es etwas was auch sie
verstehen müssen solidarität ist keine
einbahnstraße
wir sind solidarisch menschen die
bedürftig sind und die hilfe brauchen
dass es unser sozialstaatsgebot zur
solidarität gehört aber auch das
individuelle bemühen soziale leistungen
nur solange und soweit in anspruch zu
nehmen wie es wirklich notwendig ist wer
anderes verspricht verhandelt die
menschen nicht schwer
dabei begrüßen wir ja die von frau
nahles unseren haarberg angestoßene
debatte um eine reform von hartz iv
nur bitte machen wir das system da wo es
gutes nicht schlecht es hat uns ja auch
der verfestigten
langzeitarbeitslosigkeit an vielen
stellen heraus geführt
es wäre doch ein grund auch zum stolz
für bündnis 90 die grünen und die
sozialdemokratie auf diese sozialstaats
reform nicht jede regierung hat solche
grundlegenden weichenstellungen zu tage
gebracht was wir jetzt aber
notwendigerweise tun müssen ist an den
stellen zu arbeiten wo das system nicht
funktioniert es ist zu bürokratisch
deshalb kann man stärker pauschalieren
es gibt viel zu wenig betreuerinnen und
betreuer für die menschen die angebote
brauchen um wieder in arbeit oder
bildung zukommen und vor allen dingen
ist dieses system zutiefst unfair denn
vom zuverdienst beispielsweise von einem
minijob bleibt den menschen zu wenig es
muss aber gelten dass derjenige der
arbeitet auch am ende mehr einkommen am
monatsende zur verfügung hat sonst ist
ein system nicht gerecht
in diesem konkreten punkten ist zu
arbeiten liebe kolleginnen und kollegen
frau bundeskanzler hat gesprochen über
die migrationspolitik und unterstreiche
was sie gesagt haben frau
bundeskanzlerin zum migrations packt der
vereinten nationen machen uns bitte aber
klar dass dieses vorhaben zutiefst
umstritten ist natürlich ist an dem pakt
nicht alles so formuliert wie wir es
alleine hier im deutschen bundestag
beschließen würden aber es ist besser es
ist besser diesen pakt zu haben als
nicht wenn ich die öffentliche debatte
sehe habe ich aber eine befürchtung
bz wo wir heute froh während nach trump
wir hätten klare regeln für den
welthandel und den transatlantischen
handeln die zip ist von der politischen
linken durch desinformation kaputt
gemacht worden
es darf jetzt beim un migrations pakt
nicht von der politischen rechten seite
sich wiederholen und besser frage da
frage ich mich in dieser ganzen debatte
was macht eigentlich der
bundesaußenminister was macht eigentlich
der bundesaußenminister in dieser frage
das müsste doch der erste sein der für
solche internationalen solche
internationalen fragen in deutschland
öffentlichkeit schafft unser eigenes
rechts muss ebenfalls weltoffener werden
auch als das was sie vorgelegt haben
einfach kräfte zuwanderungsregelungen es
muss pragmatischer werden unser
einwanderungsrecht mit blick auf den
spurwechsel und es muss kontrollierter
und gesteuerter werden insbesondere bei
der abschiebung von illegalen und bevor
wir darüber nachdenke
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen bevor wir
darüber nachdenken wie frau kramp
karrenbauer nach syrien abzuschieben
sollten wir erst einmal erreichen dass
in die maghrebstaaten menschen
zurückgeführt werden können das würde
berlin frau bundeskanzlerin sie haben
immer die digitalstrategie gesprochen
und in dem zusammenhang auch über die
infrastruktur
wir sind in dieser frage an ihrer seite
was die ziele angeht aber wir sitzen
zweifel in den weg den sie beschreiten
wollen die ausschreibungs bestimmungen
von minister schon überzeugen uns
gegenwärtig noch nicht wir wollen
flächendeckendes netz wir wollen es
schnell
wir wollen die lücken bei 4g schließen
und wir wollen glasfaserausbau mobilfunk
der fünften generation zusammen denken
das wird nicht funktionieren wenn man
gleichzeitig einnahmen maximieren will
und diese form der daseinsvorsorge
erreicht wir haben noch historische
erfahrungen hans eichel wollte maximale
einnahmen bei den umts lizenzen einen
maximalen netzabdeckung zu fordern
dafür haben wir einen hohen preis zu
zahlen bis heute wir sollten es deshalb
für die zukunft genau umgekehrt machen
als hans eichel es damals
beschlossen jan schneider es waren 100
milliarden euro einnahme aber der
volkswirtschaftliche schaden durch
funklöcher und zu schmales breitbandnetz
in der fläche übersteigt bei weitem die
öffentlichen einnahmen von hans eichel
damals mit ganz großer sicherheit wird
kolleginnen und kollegen
mein freund otto fricke hat heute
geburtstag deshalb deshalb will ich mit
einem letzten gedanken schließen 2018
ist ein verlorenes jahr
bei der wettbewerbsfähigkeit bei der
bildung der digitalisierung im
klimaschutz bei der diese problematik
der einwanderung und europa frau
bundeskanzlerin und herr seehofer
sie beide haben erkannt dass ihre
parteien erneuerung brauchen was für
parteien richtig ist das kann für das
land das kann für die bundesrepublik
deutschland nicht falsch sein
und deshalb hoffen wir auf das neue jahr
[Applaus]